i guess my i want to ask the most
important thing first which is have any
of you guys started doing shower bath
shower as a result of that script and
episode
i did i swear i did
i i did i've been i've been infected
i was like it's true you're just sitting
there in your stuff you know
so yeah
in short i have
i have not that's uh
what you say so it's a little bit of a
waste it's a little bit of a waste yeah
not the most uh
ecological uh
and a time suck
yeah but i will say i do i do like to uh
i mean i'm a big fan of baths but i do
like to wash the hair and then do the
bath sometimes but that's a splurge
california's in a drought i shower
before i get in the bath so i don't make
the skus around the tub and you know i'm
sorry i'm not necessarily
yeah
i think people will understand this a
lot more after they've seen a little of
the show but um i guess another big
question is do you think uh john this is
for you do you think spike would leave
the ship if the if the bebop made
delicious noodles
no it's
it's part of the charm
part of the charm
one of the other things about this
series is that i really do think it's
it's pretty much just about food and
music and catching the bad guys is just
what goes on between uh eating and
discussing music do you guys
agree would i would agree with that i
also say i i really appreciate the fact
that we care about food that food is a
character in our show um because you
know so often you watch like an action
film and you were like when do they eat
when do they go take a piss and i feel
like
we keep it real
yeah i'm just starving a lot and it
comes
most of the time
it is reflective of life it does feel
like um i think sometimes uh
people define
their lives by their work and most
people define their lives by what they
do uh after work
very true
uh there's gonna be a lot of people
watching this
that have never seen the animated series
and aren't really familiar with the
characters for each of you what are you
really most excited for people to see in
this series
um i i just think it's it's the most um
creative the most unusual world
that i i personally have seen in in
cinema and um it's just really visually
rich and
strange and familiar at the same time so
that there's
um
analog mixed with the future and um i
just feel like it's a real visual
feast
and um i i think it's going to be
exciting for people who have not been
exposed to this world to enter this
world
and
um have fun exploring
um my hope is that uh because of the
time that we live in because we're
coming out of a pandemic because things
have been stressful i just really hope
that we're able to give a complete 100
escape to people and just have them have
just have fun
yeah i'm excited for for them to see our
relationships in space i think we have a
lot of fun the chemistry is really
obvious
um and so yeah i'm excited for people to
see it on a worldwide scale
i heard that all the department heads
everyone involved was told plant as many
easter eggs as you can into the series
so for you guys were you noticing that
on set that you were like seeing little
things and what what things maybe would
you like to tease like fans if you will
on like what they should look out for
well it started before we got to say you
want to go danny i would just say pay
attention to our fridge in our kitchen
yes i mean pay attention to all the like
the surfaces where their stuff but i was
just going to say quickly that um you
know the easter egg started with the
outfits man there's like there's
information all over the outfits um if
you look there's going to be like little
dogs because my character's the black
dog you'll find that on the costume and
and interesting places so yeah i'd say
just keep your eye out all over the
place because
they literally are all over yeah the
most unusual
easter egg i can say is if you can spot
the soul of spike's shoe you will find
some sheet music
on his soul and so that's the level of
detail that we're talking about um
in terms of uh the department heads and
and
[Music]
how how
what fans they were
really
i'm one of the cool things about the
show and it's already been out there is
of course the opening credits and i know
and i heard that you guys spent like a
few days actually recreating that
filming it can you sort of talk about
what it was like
creating credits from an animated series
like i mean and trying to get it right
i have a pretty personalized experience
and this might not be the answer you
were looking for but a fruitful one
which is that i was coming out of
quarantine right so i had my christmas
weight shall we say as we all did
pandemic and
my stunt double jade routini who's this
lovely lovely talented woman she's
felt and tight and thin and i was like
can we get jade to do the
the uh what do you call it once the
silhouettes
to which my show declined uh but
that's partially where my head was at
[Laughter]
it was an unusual sequence because we're
we're we're recreating these iconic
thing uh poses and stuff and
and it was more like working as a um
a model in some ways you know um
striking these poses because it was
important to get the physicality correct
and quote
the opening um
and
it was it was the one time as an actor i
just felt like yes
no more acting this is time to pose and
get it right it was like the cool it was
the most fanboy moment for me of the
whole experience was recreating that
opening because it's
um
because it's it's it's one of the most
exciting openings to any show i've ever
seen
yeah
agreed it was action figure moment
uh did you guys ever get to leave i mean
this sounds a little bit stupid but did
you ever get to leave set or want to
leave set in costume and just go to the
local like starbucks and be like you
gotta see this is so [ __ ] cool like
you gotta see what we're doing
i can't say i did
[Laughter]
i had too much
stuff on me
like prosthetics and arms and
strapped on i was like get me out of
this at the end of the day
yeah i i think there was a couple
moments though while we were shooting
where people who were just driving by or
had to like come through and like cars
of kids would like look at us and be
like
what are they like it was it was fun to
watch people walking by trying to figure
out what was going on
um i uh i dug my suit um i i won't say
that i wanted to wear it after 14
hours of shooting
but
i did it did turn me into a suit guy
like i'm i'm i'm
i'm much
more comfortable in a suit now and i'm
like you know this there's a reason why
these things have been around forever i
think you were a suit guy before though
you feel like you've always been a
suitcase i feel like i'm gonna be the
guy that wears the suit um when he gets
up and goes to uh trader joe's
that's where i'm headed right t-shirt in
a suit like
my dad wore a suit to the beach yeah i
rolled up the slacks i think i called a
new yorker okay
um on that note i gotta stop i'm just
gonna say congrats on the series i
really can't wait to finish it and i
hope it's a huge hit thank you for your
time thank you